-First night, first night.
-I know.
First time being
on this great show, also.
-I know. This is so exciting
How are you feeling going
into your first evening?
-I want to throw up.
-Yeah.
Absolutely want to throw up.
-It's a good show that we're
going to see tonight, right?
You're feeling good?
-I'm very confident
and proud of our first episode
I mean, of all the episode
we've shot thus far.
But the first episode
is like my little baby.
I'm so proud of it.
I can't wait for you to see it
I can't wait.
-Well, we're very excited.
We last saw each other in March.
You announced that you wer
doing this show
on "The Tonight Show."
-Yep.
-And then I came down.
And I was a surprise.
And we all had
some champagne together.
-Absolutely.
-Yet you did not know
I was coming.
-See, here's what happened
was we had this segment
planned out with Jimmy,
and then super last minute
my publicist was like,
"hey, none of that's happening
We're going to change it."
And I was immediately stressed
Because I thought,
"Why is this happening?"
Now I know in hindsight
it was because a surprise
was being planned.
But if I'm really honest,
there's a moment on the show
if you zoom in on my face,
when Jimmy says,
"We have a surprise."
My eyes are absolutely saying,
"Oh, my God.
The Rock is going to
come out right now."
And so I'm -- I mean,
I'm thrilled it was you.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I'm thrilled.
No, that's coming across.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, I know.
But there's definitely
a moment where I'm like,
"Dwayne Johnson
is going to come out!"
And then it was you.
And I was like, "Also fun!
-Yeah.
-"Also fun."
-I think the face was more like,
"Also fine."
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean --
-It is like -- I would never -
If I was backstage, I woul
never want someone to say,
"The audience is so excited.
We told them it was
either The Rock or you.
Now get out there and show 'em
you're not The Rock!"
-But even though you're
not The Rock, I got to say
this was one of the most special
moments of my entire life,
and you made that possible
-Oh, thank you.
Well, that's so sweet
of you to say. And --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You certainly
made a major career --
made a name for yourself
on YouTube.
-Yeah.
-15 million subscribers
to your channel.
For those who are
not familiar with you,
how do you describe yourself
to people?
-You know,
I've gone through phases.
I used to say aspiring actress
I used to say aspiring comedian.
I said entertainer for a while
-Uh-huh.
-But the thing is, every tim
I'd crossed customs
and I would tell the customs
officer "entertainer,"
I could tell
he was like, "Stripper."
-Right, yeah.
-And then I was like,
"Why, thank you."
But I think what I --
I think the label, if you will
that I really enjoy now
is just storyteller.
-That's a good one.
-I enjoy telling stories.
I think stories connect humans
Stories make the world
go 'round.
People feel represented
in stories.
And stories are what
make people feel empowered
So I'm a storyteller.
-You have built this audienc
over the years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Give it up for telling stories
-What a supportive audience!
Oh, my goodness!
I love you. I love you all
-You have -- You have
very supportive fans.
You have built your career
in front of them, in real time
Those who have been
early adopters
have really seen this rise
What was it like when you firs
started having fan reactions
of people who knew you
from YouTube
and were seeing you in person?
-You know, I think the first
couple people that approached me
were taken aback
by how nerdy I was.
Because the first couple peopl
came up to me, and I was like,
"Can I get a picture with you?
Can I get your autograph?
This is so cool for me."
It's just surreal because I'm,
like, a weird nerd, you know
And so when people look at m
and say things like,
"You're so cool, and I wan
to follow your footsteps,"
I'm like, "You're sure?
Are you sure?"
I'm just a weirdo.
And I'm glad they find
inspiration from me.
-You are a Canadian hero.
Is it safe to say that?
-Oh, yeah. A hero?
A Canadian, yes.
-Well, you -- Here you are
with the Toronto Raptor.
-Yes. Yes, yes, yes.
-That's very exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I personally -- Yep.
I like to feel like I personally
won the NBA championship.
-As you should.
-Yes.
-You grew up in Ontario.
-And were you --
Was this something --
Would your parents
have guessed at a young ag
that you wanted to be someon
who was in the public eye?
Who liked to perform?
-I think so.
You know,
I was a very rebellious,
annoying child growing up.
Everything from wanting to
paint my room a certain colo
to wanting to make weird video
on the Internet.
I think my parents know
if I want to do something,
I'm going to do it.
I used to be a dancer, as well
Which they did not like.
And I had to convince them
about that, too.
My life has always been abou
I want to do something.
Mom and dad
aren't going to like it.
How do we still do it?
-And did they --
Was it easy to sell them on,
"Hey, I'm going to make videos
on the Internet"?
Was that something
that they immediately said
"Great. This is what we hoped.
-Was it easy to sell
my Indian immigrant parent
on the idea of making videos
for the Internet?
No.
-No, it wasn't.
-No, it was not.
I mean, I think to my benefit,
they didn't really know
what that meant.
So they were just like,
"Okay, do it for a year,
and then when you fail,
you can go back to grad school."
But, you know, they did
the best thing they could.
They said, "You have a year.
Try as hard as you can.
If it goes somewhere, great.
If not, we'll talk about it.
And that year I hustled so hard.
I taught myself how to edit.
I saved up to buy my
first camera. It was $699.
I almost threw up
when I bought it.
And I just taught myself
how to play the YouTube game
And, thankfully,
it went somewhere.
-And here you are
with your show on tonight.